hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a professor of
philosophy and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called reason
IO where we put philosophy into practice I've
studied and taught Philosophy for over 20 years
and I find that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the text
is structured but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners I've been
producing longer lecture videos and posting them
to YouTube many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part of a new
series of shorter videos each of them focused on
One Core concept from an important philosophical
text I hope you find it useful as well at the
very end of part two of his proma to any future
metaphysics Emmanuel Kant has an appendix to Pure
natural science which is called of the system of
the categories and you know if you know much about
Kant even from sort of preliminary or summary work
you know that this notion of the categories is
really one of uh the the keystones of his work
but it's not something radically new at least
in its terminology because Aristotle had a very
famous book called the categories and and in it
Aristotle distinguish 10 different categories
this runs uh throughout his works you see these
coming up in the metaphysics and the nican ethics
and in other places as well and so this is part of
Aristotle's metaphysics and K thinks that that's
where Aristotle and successors to Aristotle have
actually gone wrong K thinks that he is for the
first time providing a gen genuine system of
the categories and so he begins this section
by talking about something that I think we can
generalize even further he says there can be
nothing more desirable to a philosopher than to
be able to derive the scattered multiplicity a
plurality of the concepts right or the principal
G zet which had occurred to him in rete use from
a principle uh priority and to unite everything
in this way in one cognition now that's a very
long fancy way of saying what we want to do when
we're actually engaging in metaphysics or ontology
or you know this sort of uh you know let's call
it categorical work is to take everything and
say well we've got something that connects these
they're not simply isolated or opposed principles
or concepts they actually all fit together
in some sort of order and he says that uh he
formally only believed that those things which
remained after a certain abstraction and seem
by comparison to constitute a particular kind of
cognitions were completely collected but this was
just an act aggregate an aggregate is when you're
taking a bunch of things and kind of heaping them
up together right so they're not really all
that systematically connected with each other
instead what is happening is you're just kind of
throwing them all in a corner and saying there you
go that's not yet a system uh for a cun he says
now he knows that just so many neither more nor
less this number ing is very important to him can
constitute this kind of cognition and perceives
the necessity of his division this constitutes
comprehension fully understanding something only
now has he attained a system so you don't want an
aggregate you want an actual system and notice the
ways that he talks about this comprehending it
you grasping it as a totality dividing things
from from each other and not dividing them sort of
willy-nilly but along the reasonable lines coming
up with the right number no more no less saying
that you've actually worked it out fully and he
he's got a really interesting analogy here that
he's going to make to how it is that we research
a language in a scientific way and and it's good
to keep in mind that by this time not not only has
grammar been around and taught for a very long
time it was part of the you know trivia in the
Middle Ages but there starting to formulate laws
regularities of languages themselves and to do
comparative study of language which is really
going to take off much more in the following
Century but it's already got its Beginnings there
so K says to search in our ordinary knowledge for
the concepts which do not rest on particular
experience and yet occurrent all knowledge from
experience okay that's what Kant has been working
on um presupposes neither greater reflection nor
deeper Insight than to detect in a language the
rules of the actual use of words generally and
thus to collect elements for a grammar this is an
activity that was going on at the time uh people
would go to you know uh far off place es meet
with people whose language they didn't understand
start to learn that language try to figure out
how does this language actually work and then
they would write grammars of it missionaries for
example did that with Native American tribes that
they encountered so he says in fact both of these
inquiries are very closely related Now isn't that
an interesting idea it's not just an analogy he's
saying that there's a kind of connection between
linguistic work and let's call it metaphysical
work so he goes on and he says what's what's the
similarity even though we're not able to give
a reason why each language has just this and
no other formal Constitution and still less why
exactly so many neither more nor less of such
formal determinations in general can be found in
it well it's the same with the categories of the
understanding there 's the amount that you've
got and you know we can't actually provide an
ultimate explanation for why exactly these but
we can say here they are right so Kant goes on
and he says all right what about Aristotle and
he's going to call Aristotle's work a raps at
several different points and this is actually
a derogatory term in this case right the rapods
are people who are divinely inspired by the gods
to either write poetry or interpret poetry they
don't really know what they're doing this goes all
the way back to uh Plato's dialogue the ion K has
this in mind he's like saying you know aerosol is
a smart guy but he really didn't know what he was
doing when he came up with these categories nor
are the people following him trying to make these
categories work really knowing what they're
engaged with so he says Aristotle collected
10 pure Elementary Concepts under the name of
categories right and uh here we've got a slightly
different organization than how it's typically
laid out in Aristotle's book so what are they
um well substance what what it is that you know
is the subject uh not not uh in something else
other things are predicated of it stays the same
over time quantity how much quality kind right
relatives uh Pro T in relation to place time you
can say space if you want to as well um literally
asking where when position how things are laid out
uh having like you know wearing a tie action and
passion and then in the the uh footnote here we
have in Latin substania qualitas quantitas relio
AIO posio so action and passion are being moved
in quando ubitus habitus right uh so so uh when
we see him referring to the seventh and eth and
Ninth what we're talking about there is Place time
and position spatial temporal uh qualifiers we
could say so he says uh to these which were also
called predicaments he found himself obliged to
add five post predicaments some of which are uh
contained in the former but this raps so you see
that term must be considered and commended as a
mere hint for future inquirers not as a regularly
worked out idea and so it has been in the present
more advanced state of philosophy rejected is
quite useless well rejected by some still used
by others and Kant is going to be uh one of the
rejectors because he says it's not systematic
um and he says after long reflection on the
pure elements of human knowledge I succeeded
in distinguishing with certainty and in separating
the pure Elementary concepts of sensibility space
and time from those of the understanding so
really important initial division there that
we saw carried out earlier in the proma thus
the seventh eth and Ninth categories had to be
excluded from the old list the others he said were
of no service to me because there was no principle
on which the understanding could be fully mapped
out and all the functions determined exhaustively
and with Precision you could ask Aristotle where
did you come up with this list why these what's
the connection here and Aristotle might say
well you know substance is primary all these
other things these other nine are predicated of
substance and then somebody like H could come
along and go well that's fine but that doesn't
really tell you why quantity quality relations
should be different from each other why did you
come up with this list and what about these weird
ones like action and passion seem to be kind
of correlatives or having you know why why
isn't that included under something like quality
right and Aristotle doesn't really have answers
to provide so this does seem to be a serious
criticism so con says okay how do we proceed
then what's what's my Approach well let's focus
on an act of the understanding a kind of Acts in
general that we can then abstract about an act
of the understanding fand is HL something that
the understanding does not just a single action
but something that it does over and over and over
over again um well what is that judging judgment
right the uh connecting things together in certain
ways saying this is this or this has this quality
or this has this modality or what you know this
this quantity or whatever we're going to say
so he goes on and he says that um I found this
act of the understanding consists in judging here
the labors of the logicians were ready to at hand
though not entirely free from defects and with
this help I was enabled to exhibit to put out
there uh a complete table of the pure functions
and there he uses the word uh you know F fun
functions of the understanding what it is that the
understanding does in engaging in these judgments
so he says these were undetermined in regard to
any object so they can be applied to any of them
and he says I finally referred these functions
of judging to objects in general or rather to the
condition of determining judgments as objectively
valid so they can be used for empirical matters
singulars particulars but they can be used across
the board for anything that we can apply them to
and so he says though so there arose the pure
concepts of the understanding concerning which
I could make certain that these and this exact
number only notice again the insistence on we've
got the right amount of these uh categories
or concepts constitute our whole cognition
of things from Pure understanding then he says I
was justified in calling them categories the old
name because that's what they're actually doing
and he said I reserved for myself the liberty of
adding under the title of predicables all the
concepts deducible from them by combinations
whether among themselves or with the pure form of
the appearance that is space or time or with its
matter uh as soon as a system of transcendental
philosophy should be completed the construction
of which I was engaged in the critique of pure
reason so he's saying I I already did this in the
critique of pure reason and now here he says the
essential point in this my system of categories
which distinguishes it from the old raps City the
Aristotelian category which proceeded without any
principle is this by means of it the true meaning
of the pure concepts of the understanding and the
condition of their use could be exactly determined
they are themselves nothing but logical functions
and do not constitute the least concept of an
object in itself No Numa no Ding and Z right
but require some sensuous intuition as a basis
so this means as he's going to say you can only
apply these categories of the understanding to our
experiential uh engagement with a spaciotemporal
world right uh in which we we exist and have
perceptions but also apply our understanding
as well so you can't apply this as others are
doing uh as he's going to say if you think
about previous metaphysics whether aristotles
or that of others they're mixing up two kinds
of Concepts they're mixing up the things that
are phenomenal and we you know make judgments
of experience by means of bringing in the peer
concepts of the understanding which we've seen
are derived in this way there there's that and
then there's things that go beyond that they are
transcendental right or Transcendent and they
have to do with as Kant is going to call it um
matters of pure reason or reflection um a little
bit later on he'll say that these are foreign
Concepts which might otherwise intrude among the
pure concepts of the understanding um and he says
we can organize them too we can organize them
into tables but we have to take our cue from the
categories the concepts of the understanding not
just jump into this other world and we better not
mix all these things up together and say we're
doing metaphysics because if we do we're being
unsystematic and we're going beyond the bounds
of possible experience and we're going to get
ourselves into all sorts of as he's going to call
it confusion right my systematic division saves us
from confusion he says and he tells us that the
concepts of Reason are of quite another nature
and origin so they can have a table they can have
an organization they can have a system but it's
going to be as he says uh quite another form from
that of the concepts of the understanding this
so necessary separation he goes on has never yet
been made in any system of metaphysics where as a
rule these ideas of Reason are all mixed up with
the concepts of the understanding like children
belonging to one family a confusion is where he
concludes this that was unavoidable in the absence
of a definite system of categories so K system
of categories is really doing three things one is
it's replacing the totally inadequate Aristotelian
raps of the 10 categories and you know five other
things mixed into that work ah we're getting
rid of that it's also providing us with the
comprehensive system according to Kant for the
understanding and it's helping us to draw a neat
dividing line between the categories and concepts
of the understanding and those of a different
faculty that of pure reason which we don't want to
blend in there and thereby you know get everything
confused so having a system of the categories
turns out to be very very important from K's
perspective
that